Vous savez quel jour on est ?
Le jour d'aller me faire cramer le cul.
Allez, c'est parti.
Non...
Là c'est mes waters.
Voilà, donc c'est la septième séance sur les six prévues au départ
donc à partir d'aujourd'hui je passe officiellement en hors forfait.
Ce que je vous propose c'est d'y aller directement, comme ça ce sera fait
et puis après je reviens et on discute de tout ça, d'accord ?
Allez, c'est parti !
J'espère que cette fois ça va se passer mieux que la dernière fois,
je vous redis ça après.
Faut vraiment que j'aille chez le coiffeur aussi !
Mais c'est un autre problème ça.
Chaque chose en son temps.
(vous-êtes prêt?) Ouais, allons-y, ouais.
(musique metal)
(Ça va ?)
Ouais, ça va.
(Voix off) Faux !
C'est de plus en plus long, hein
Ouais
Voilà c'est fait donc, comme vous avez vu ça a fait encore un petit peu mal
un petit peu très mal même, mais je suis resté extrêmement digne.
C'est faux.
Je rentre chez moi et puis on débrief' un peu tout ça
Voilà c'est fini !
Alors, petit rituel comme d'habitude maintenant
Ça, c'est la photo du tatouage juste avant la séance
Donc, comme vous voyez depuis deux mois ça n'a pas bougé
Et ça c'est la photo du tatouage juste après la séance quand j'ai retiré le pansement
C'est encore bien gonflé, bien joli, hein !
Alors comme vous avez vu bah j'ai encore eu bien mal
J'ai même l'impression que c'est de plus en plus douloureux en fait
Si ça marchait, je crois que c'est vraiment un truc que je supporterai sans problème
mais bon là, on va pas se mentir, ça marche pas de ouf.
Donc pour faire un petit peu le point
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez la dernière fois le médecin m'avait dit que
il avait l'impression que l'encre réagissait de moins en moins bien au laser
donc je lui ai reposé la question aujourd'hui
je lui ai demandé si c'était toujours le cas
il m'a dit : "oui effectivement ça ne fonctionne pas bien,
voire pas du tout"
Donc j'ai demandé si c'était à son avis un problème de quantité d'encre ou un problème de qualité d'encre
donc pour lui c'est très clairement la qualité de l'encre.
Il m'a dit : "C'est une encre qui est trop coriace"
Il a employé le mot "coriace"
En 2018.
Alors du coup, j'ai recontacté Hama et Julien,
les deux tatoueurs du studio Keller
qui m'avaient fait le tatouage il y a maintenant plus d'un an
et je leur ai demandé quelle encre ils avaient utilisé
donc ils m'ont envoyé les références.
Et cette encre là, d'après eux c'est l'encre noire la plus couramment utilisée par les tatoueurs
ce que m'a confirmé une pote à moi qui est tatoueuse, qui utilise aussi cette encre là
et qui m'a dit : "C'est vraiment la base quoi"
Je me dis si son laser, au gars, il marche pas
Ou mal ? "Pas", on va pas se mentir
Si le laser marche pas sur l'encre la plus courante
et sur du noir en plus, c'est à dire la couleur qui est sensé être la moins difficile à faire partir
Du coup, comment ça se passe, j'veux dire : ça marche sur quoi ?
et puis un autre truc qui m'a un peu chagriné, mais ça c'était la semaine dernière
C'est un truc qu'a dit Tintin, le tatoueur, hein, pas le journaliste belge en papier
Tintin, donc le tatoueur, qui disait sur Europe 1
bah il disait ça écoutez!: " si c'est un truc qui a été fait par un vrai
professionnel bonne chance pour le faire retirer même au laser !" voilà
n'est pas très pas très encourageant c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire j'ai rediscuté avec
différentes personnes et notamment ma pote tatoueuse et je pense que ce coup là je vais considérer
à 90% que c'était mon dernier
rendez-vous dans ce centre de laser.  Je n'ai pas repris de rendez-vous d'ailleurs je me laisse un peu de temps de réfléchir je pense que
je vais vraiment tester un
laser de dernière génération un truc un peu plus puissant. Voilà l'idée de départ c'était de tester le laser basique le
truc sur lequel on tombe le plus facilement quand on cherche à
retirer un tatouage au laser sur paris sur google donc du coup j'ai fait l'expérience avec un tatoueur pro
l'encre la plus courante un motif assez classique quoi un
portrait en tracé
donc la technique de laser la plus facilement trouvable le truc de base j'ai pas envie de continuer encore
un an deux ans comme ça vraiment vu les résultats que j'ai là je vais passer à la vitesse supérieure je pense
"Il y a des nouveaux lasers
tant mieux parce que ça sauve la vie de certaines personnes qui ont vraiment fait n'importe quoi..."
non parce que là on va pas se voiler la face
ça bouge pas, du tout donc on verra d'ici quelques semaines puisqu'il faut attendre le temps que
les cellules fassent leur boulot mais la voilà à quoi ça ressemble le lendemain de la séance de laser là
et la voilà à quoi ça ressemble le surlendemain donc deux jours
deux jours après ce n'est pas probant voilà j'ai donc employé le terme probant fun fact c'était peut-être la dernière fois que je voyais
le médecin en question
il a réalisé aujourd'hui
que c'était pas le portrait du capitaine haddock qu'il était en train de décider de me faire partir du cul depuis plus d'un an
voilà il a compris aujourd'hui même que c'était cyril hanouna en fait voilà
Il n'est jamais trop tard ! Ah oui, un autre truc aussi vous avez été très très très très nombreuses et très très nombreux à m'envoyer
plein d'articles sur cette équipe de chercheurs marseillais qui aura fait une découverte sur la façon dont l'encre des tatouages
reste dans la peau et donc potentiellement sur...
fin, ca ouvrirait potentiellement la voie à de nouvelles techniques de détatouage. donc vous m'avez vraiment envoyé je l'ai reçu
je pense 200 ou 300 fois par différentes voies du coup bah évidemment que ça m'intéresse
pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que bah ça remet en question ce que je vous dis dans ma vidéo sur le tatouage
donc ça peut être intéressant de mettre un petit peu à jour les informations
et puis ensuite bien sûr le détatouage voilà on vient d'en parler pendant quelques minutes là vous comprenez bien que ça m'intéresse
donc je les ai contactés j'ai eu un début de réponse donc
normalement si tout va bien d'ici quelques semaines j'aurais discuté avec eux pour savoir vraiment de quoi
de quoi il en retourne
et puis bien évidemment je vous raconterai tout ça en vidéo voilà du coup vous avez compris vous me me sentez venir
dtc là c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
J'entends rien d'ici là oui voilà d'ici là mettez vous bien et portez vous bien Ciao!
Oui bonsoir est ce que c'est possible de prendre un rendez vous pour une coupe des cheveux demain